j'aime pas du tout choqué je déteste le
malaise en général dans la vie réelle je
déteste le malaise j'aurais pu être
pédophile enfin je veux dire qu'on a un
pays où on a un peu le droit de faire du
politiquement incorrect
[Musique]
j'ai grandi une famille d'intello donc
il y avait déjà un patrimoine culturel
après pendant mes études en socio je me
suis j'ai commencé à aimer écrire je
trouve ces inventions formidables le
langage
[Musique]
que vous a appris Jamel qu'on était là
pour s'amuser quand même j'avais envie
de faire ce métier mais je
ça me traumatisait quand même vraiment
beaucoup ouais je pense que c'est lui
qui m'a fait comprendre que il y avait
un
vrai échange de de conneries à faire
avec le public
[Musique]
le futur ça me fait pas rire du tout
le futur
un maximum parce que je sens bien qu'on
est tous on est vraiment en train de
prendre
le mauvais chemin vraiment
[Musique]
c'est plutôt une satire du de l'humain
occidental moderne
[Musique]
je pense que les sujets les plus
dramatiques sont les sujets les plus
drôles à traiter de toute façon
[Musique]
au rythme où ça s'aggrave au rythme ou
la pauvreté s'aggrave en France au
rythme ou le gouvernement casse les
conditions de possibilité d'une
politique de logement juste donc au
rythme tout ça va je pense que l'année
prochaine c'est pas un Zénith qu'il
faudra faire c'est un Parc des Princes
[Musique]
pour la première fois
on me donnait la responsabilité d'un
vrai rôle d'un vrai personnage à
composer et c'était pas n'importe qui
c'était carverne de l'épine donc que je
dis donc j'admirais depuis très
longtemps de loin et donc quand ils sont
venus me proposer ça j'étais très très
impressionné et je savais pas comment
faire parce que moi j'ai pas fait
d'études d'art dramatique
[Musique]
le plus de yoga de la méditation et on
envoie beaucoup d'amour mais mais
envoyer des dons c'est bien parce que
c'est concret et un autre monde est
possible oui mais un monde magique et
solidaire ne va pas sortir magiquement
de la terre à la fin du confinement donc
c'est c'est maintenant qu'on peut agir
[Musique]
c'est un faux documentaire qui a tous
les atouts d'un vrai tourné caméra à
l'épaule nous sommes plongés dans la vie
quotidienne de Blanche Gardin qui
s'adresse souvent à la caméra convaincu
que ces blagues l'ont fait pourrir de
l'intérieur et que l'humour se fait
forcément au détriment des autres
blanche Gardin se met en quête de son
bien-être et de son féminin sauvage
[Musique]